all right so it's time for the goats in
a bad way coming out of wild card
weekend i hate going negative i really
do and i mean that when i say that a
little bit all right question
positive now that we only have four
games like because it's hard to go
negative two here okay all right if you
get it right you get the first pick
tuatanga vialoa announced that he will
skip his senior season at alabama and
enter the nfl draft this year
when he does get picked he'll be the
only left-handed quarterback in the nfl
who is the last left-handed quarterback
to throw a touchdown pass in the
national football league and i'll give
you a hint he's currently coaching a
team that didn't make it to the playoffs
as an assistant yeah with callan moore
then right yeah i get it
that was too nice
what color is blue
you were very nice thank you thank you
for doing that i felt bad i felt bad
because without the hint what the hell
how are you going to remember it was
kellen moore yeah yeah no i know and uh
well there has you know the crazy thing
is there just hasn't been that many
lefty quarterbacks here in the last 10
15 years it's crazy it's a dying breed
so yeah i think i think you scared
everybody off i did yep go play baseball
and go pitch something like that
um all right so
wow there's uh there's a few options
here okay i'm gonna go with two
defenders right for the buffalo bills as
being goats of the week for me and you
know they did a lot of good things here
but they didn't make the play
to finish it and that's where i'm going
to go with number 33 saron neil and 58
matt milano for the buffalo bills on
that missed tackle with deshawn watson
hey you know it's second and six you got
the guy right in your sights two guys
there to make a sack
cause third third and thirteen third and
twelve gonna put the texans in a really
tough spot and to not come away with
that tackle and let watson escape and
then ultimately find the game-winning
completion uh that was a huge moment in
that game of course and yes i mean tough
luck lucky great player whatever it may
be i know that neil and milano would
both agree they should have made that
tackle it didn't happen and that's why
they'll be at home watching desean
watson this weekend
yeah a lot of potential goats you could
point to from the bills side in that
game whether it's coach sean mcdermott
whether it's players you could throw
josh allen in there for what he did in
the second half but i'm gonna stay with
that game okay and i'm not gonna pick on
anyone from the buffalo bills i've been
waiting to vent about this on the show
we didn't have a chance yesterday to get
to it we will probably have airing
grievances tomorrow but who knows
whether i'll remember by then tony
corente is my number one go to the week
because
that that routine
at the start of the second half when the
guy
fields the kickoff after he does the
universal i'm not coming out all clear
catches the ball clearly is giving
himself up and flips it in the direction
of corenti who treats it like a used
diaper and runs out of the way and does
that walt anderson style technicality
gotcha bull crap had to stop myself
there oh that is shameful it's a poor
reflection on kareni it's a poor
reflection on al riveron the senior vp
of officiating it's a poor reflection on
the entire national football league that
one of 17 nfl referees would have so
little common sense in that moment and
think that there was some hyper
technical application of the rules that
was going to be used to screw the texans
there that was wrong and it was good
that they fixed it yes but we never
should have been exposed to that
underbelly for two minutes of like are
you serious that they're actually
considering calling this a touchdown and
even then he was wrong to call it a
touchdown it was an illegal forward pass
and a safety that's what it was not a
touchdown but even then it was a touch
back the play was over and here's where
common sense also goes haywire here all
the guy had to do is let the ball hit
the ground and it's automatically a
touch back yeah there's no reason to
even catch it in the end zone right and
maybe that's the lesson in the event
that you've got some referee that's that
that just has a misfire in his brain why
are you even fielding that kick just let
it hit the ground yeah i i agree i mean
that was uh a really odd moment right
there and
i would imagine you'd see those same
mechanics
at least once a game in every game
throughout the year in the nfl yeah the
guy catches the ball 99 yards deep in
the end zone and just does this like
that's what they do i mean we're at the
a you know we're in the age of player
safety we realize yeah you don't you
know there's guys aren't returning the
ball as often and certainly not from
nine yards deep in the end zone so
you're right that was true they're
trying to reduce physical violence on
kickoff return so he's going to let that
be a live ball yeah and then you have 15
guys colliding in the end zone for a
live ball it really it really upset me
at the time and i'm glad i had a chance
to vent about it yep good so tony
corente you get the goat horns okay and
maybe you could do it tomorrow and
really feel good on grievances too um
but all right so that's a good one i'm
gonna go with jim schwartz as a goat for
me this week a little bit okay and the
philadelphia eagles defensive
coordinator what he did in that game you
know you heard me all last week and on
the pre-game show sunday on football
night in america about
don't don't protect the corners in
philadelphia especially in this recent
game against the seattle seahawks the
seattle seahawks
no starting right guard in iupati no
starting left tackle and dwayne brown
you know the two the two running backs
that play for them not there rashad
penny chris carson there's issues in the
run game
you know
phil seattle's not running the ball you
know you got a great defensive front in
in in philadelphia
the running backs in that game just so i
can get this right too
have 17 carries for 19 yards but there
we were in the third quarter and late in
the second quarter with nine guys at the
line of scrimmage philadelphia like they
were playing like walter payton back in
the early 80s or something you know no
they can't run the ball protect your
corners get them get the safeties deep
what are we doing why are you giving the
seahawks their only hope to move the
ball which is russell wilson taking deep
shots down the field to the freaky dk
metcalf it's like he was literally going
like here you guys go here here i'll
i'll give you a completion you ready you
ready you want it you want it you think
you can hit it oh yeah well i can't hit
it i'm russell wilson i make 35 million
a year of course yes i can hit it and dk
metcalf's like a first-round pick who
somehow was the second last pick of the
second round so uh that one i just don't
understand to me you didn't like these
two plays are the perfect example it's
third and ten you got a chance to get
the ball back
why are we got why are you doing all out
blitz
and leaving it to oh i could throw it up
to dk metcalf well i don't understand
the thought process there so that
frustrated me and that's why he's a goat
for me this week the good news is he has
an interview with the browns to be their
head coach too so maybe maybe jimmy
hasn't been watching that game all right
i'm i'm gonna go with and and we're
gonna we're gonna finish the draft uh
after this pick we'll do it in the final
segment because we've kind of elaborated
a little too much on these picks yeah
but i'm going to go with bill belichick
the greatest of all time as a head coach
gets the gold horns here's why here's
why
that that that whole clock management
that that that loophole that he for
whatever reason told the world about in
the in the jets game when they were up
30 to nothing or something like that and
they burned a lot of extra time off the
clock with intentional penalties and
whatnot like why are you telling anybody
about that when there's a chance it's
going to be used against you between
that moment and next march when they
change the rule his whole point was they
need to change the rule well wait until
the competition committee meets to let
them know they need to change the rule
keep your mouth shut about it and that's
the great irony here the guy who never
says anything that is of any value to
anyone at a press conference had that
one moment of vanity where he decided
need to let everyone know how smart he
is and that's why he did what he did and
his his protege mike frable used it
against him and chewed up a bunch of
time in the fourth quarter so look i'm
reluctant to say it because i like it
when bill belichick talks but this is
all the more reason for him to never say
anything well you're right i mean uh
again it was brilliant by mike vrabel
and it all worked out and i think he had
a good feel for the way the game went um
you know
i'd love to know here's what i'd love to
know did frable know about it yes
belichick told the world that's what i
was gonna say like did he did he know i
would like to think that they knew that
already but you know i don't know to
your point maybe it brought it on
everybody's radar some coaches in the
nfl who weren't totally aware of it and
thought wow that's really cool i'm going
to do that if the chance ever you know
presents itself it did vervel and that
was big time
all right we are two rounds into our
three round goats in a bad way draft
from wild card weekend chris sims you're
up well the nfl pi rule that's what it's
one of the goats of the weekend because
guess what
we were in new orleans and guess what
took away from a great game once again
oh good old nfl pi replay review oh gosh
great game upset oh let's totally take
the credibility away of the game and
maybe it was past interference i mean
did kyle rudolph push off yeah he did
yes did pj williams initiate contact by
putting his hands on him first yes he
did but because we have this rule in
place now because of one play over 52 or
53 super bowl years
uh now that's everybody wants to talk
about the next day or that day of the
game i mean it's it's marred is mard the
right way it's marked at the spot it's
the sport a little bit and it's just
annoying to me and i wish it would go
away i'm sick of it i don't like it and
it's annoying okay so yeah i think it
goes
it is going to go away after this season
the question is what will they put in
its place that's going to be one of the
challenges and hopefully this time
around because i got the impression last
year rich mckay and the competition
committee didn't have a whole lot of
ideas to bring to the table at the
league meetings they thought they'd be
able to convince everyone this is a
100-year event and we don't have to
worry about it and there was kind of a
revolt from the coaches and the gm's and
they had to come up with something this
is the best they could come up with yeah
in a compressed time frame hopefully
they can come up with better all right
for me the last one sorry i love you
jerry jones you're great for the sport
but
to handle jason garrett the way you did
and to announce the firing during a
playoff game i mean stand down and wait
for the damn games to end or do it
before the games start what are you
trying to prove by issuing an
announcement that jason garrett's been
fired while the eagles are playing a
playoff game it's bad form it's a bad
look the whole thing of having jason
garrett twist in the win for a week is
disrespectful remember all the reports
they're showing an abundance of care and
respect what was careless and it was
disrespectful the way they treated him
culminating in trying to bigfoot and we
joked about it on friday hey he's going
to try to bigfoot the playoff weekend he
did he announced it during the damn game
come on just wait till the game's over
wait till the next morning just don't do
it during a playoff game let that moment
have its have its moment and then take
care of business afterwards well i yeah
yeah i i know it is really weird now but
do you think he did it with like that
kind of intention or did it more of like
he was trying to do a respectful thing
to jason garrett by kind of
how how's it responsible i know i don't
know i guess because it's not learning
it's not a stand-alone thing to where it
becomes
the only thing we talk about during a
day it's like he tried to like you know
take the the burden off of jason garrett
a little bit by announcing the playoff
game so either way saturday night don't
do it during a game yeah don't do it
during a game during a game involving
one of your arch rivals the team that
took the playoff spot that you thought
you had it just comes off as petty if it
was deliberate yeah tone deaf if it
wasn't and uh for for for but look here
we are we're talking about the cowboys
again so jerry jones wins we find ways
to talk about america's t
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports